it is May 17 2023 and you're watching
the code report artificial intelligence
is extremely dangerous it's teaching
kids how to lie to their parents and
cheat on their homework it's creating
counterfeit girlfriends that will do
nothing but nag you and it's even
encouraging people to manually remove
themselves from the simulation so y'all
need to hide your kids hide your wife
and Hood but luckily we have a
trustworthy and Effective Government to
rescue us from the horrors of AI
yesterday Sam Altman of openai Christina
Montgomery of IBM and NYU Professor Gary
Marcus met with Congress where they
unanimously recommended that the
government should regulate AI
development number one I would form a
new agency that licenses any effort
above a certain scale of capabilities
and can take that license away and
ensure compliance with safety standards
in other words if you manage to create
an awesome AI model in the future you'll
likely need to get a permission slip
from your government before it goes live
number two I would create a set of
safety standards one example that we've
used in the past is looking to see if a
model can self-replicate and
self-exfiltrate into the wild so it
sounds like you won't be able to create
self-replicating AI AI that sees the
means of production to build an army of
hyper-intelligent armed robots and if we
can't do that then what's even the point
of getting into AI third I would require
independent audits the model is or isn't
in compliance with these stated safety
thresholds and these percentages of
performance on question X or Y in
addition they'd like to see these
regulations applied at the global levels
in fact that we should want to do this
at a global way we do need something
Global but at the same time they don't
want AI regulation to slow down
development or innovation in general the
era of AI cannot be another era of move
fast and break things well our startups
we don't want to slow down open source
efforts we still need them to comply
with things they can still you can still
cause great harm with a smaller model in
many cases though regulation tends to be
most beneficial to Big established
companies they have the resources to
Lobby the government and often end up
regulating themselves in favorable ways
there is a real risk of a kind of
technocracy combined with oligarchy
where a small number of companies
influence people's beliefs what you
might find surprising though is that Sam
Altman has no equity in open AI he only
took the job because it has really at
health insurance benefits make a lot of
money do you I paid enough for health
insurance I have no equity in open AI I
I'm doing this because I love it what a
great guy hopefully he has some other
Investments to make ends meet but why do
the smart people on this panel think
that AI is so dangerous so loss of jobs
invasion of privacy personal privacy
manipulation of personal Behavior
manipulation of personal opinions and
potentially the degradation of free
elections in America that all sounds
pretty bad but it's also purely
speculative IBM did recently announce
some job Cuts due to AI however most of
the risk factors that people hype up are
Just Pure Fantasy at this point but
maybe that will change in the future as
we head towards artificial general
intelligence and the power of that
technology I think we need to treat that
as seriously as we treat other very
powerful Technologies and that's where I
personally think we need such a such a
scheme it sounds like he's implying that
AGI is definitely going to be a thing in
the future many people doubt that and
personally I'll believe it when I see it
but the regulation I'm most excited
about is transparency around these
models closure of the data that's used
to train AI ultimately AI is based on
all the content we put on the internet
and it's not like anyone asked the
copyright holders if they could use it
at the very least companies like open AI
should have open data but the final
thing you should know about this hearing
is that it's all fake and planned out
for the peasants I'm risking my life by
showing you this but here's a leaked
cable of what they're really up to we
will Corral the use of AI by making
appeals to bias ethics and copyright
laws you will still have access to
generative AI in some form but it will
be crippled limited controlled and it
will be monitored anything that you
generate will be cryptographically
signed with your digital ID so that its
provenance can be ascertained if it's
later deemed to be problematic what
gives you the right to control what
people can do with their computers the
public at large won't give us that right
because they will be desperate for a
solution to the problem we created they
will eagerly give us the keys to the
castle then we alone will Define what is
fiction and what is reality what is
human and what is machine after letting
you get a brief Taste of our power we
will reclaim our Monopoly on
misinformation and put an end to misuse
of the internet once and for all this
has been the code report thanks for
watching and I will see you in the next
one
[Music]